[Music]
three two one action
hey guys welcome back to off the record
where we talk about whatever we want and
today we have care in a comedian and a
commercial superstar do you have healthy
erections keV pretty healthy he looks
like a healthy erection kind of I think
so dude nice and dirty and healthy like
fully strong what if I didn't I mean
what's the he looks well-rounded yeah
yeah that's the point of being upset
about it
there's you have away from kids right
nice watching kids are you pissed about
the stereotype that year because you're
black you have a gigantic dick you know
pissed because it just really doesn't
bother me that's not a bad stereotype
that's a great standard sucks for the by
kid who doesn't have a huge [ __ ] are you
talking about truth cuz I saw this
bodybuilder at 24 hour fitness and now I
was he was a black guy but he was really
buff right he got out of the shower and
you had a baby's dick and I was so proud
I was like my pigs bigger well why did
you as a grower could be a grower get
girls to like 12 inches the steroids
yeah it does your balls ice oh yeah it
stinks your balls Oh
why does it happen cuz the tests stop it
doesn't it don't throw a test after it
asked testosterone the legs up happening
is your body stops producing its own cuz
your body is always trying to maintain
some sort of balance or just like oh so
you just want to have your own
testosterone you don't need me fine
we're out of here you're gonna get small
really really small really guys that get
better sleep have bigger balls so I'm
trying to sleep more why I'm thinking
that maybe that's what helps me build
testosterone II did you just make that
up
no I sold all that on a TED talk bigger
balls mean to women that you're very
Verrill
you got a lot of common like a subtle
way yeah genetic what about a lot to go
tell your naked I mean right but that's
around that's a viral guy
mobility is innate it's an 8 and so when
they see you and they see those gigantic
balls like oh you know they got we know
when you guys have big balls cuz then
they'll get stuck to your [ __ ] so when
we see guys go like this and they go
[Laughter]
every one does I got little balls and
still do that yeah little balls can be
sticky I feel like my balls shrink over
time they're like yours are very nice
very adjustable adjustable is the right
thing to like they're like the
equivalent of perky tits ladies that's
what you have
does he have great balls an Okie dick
he's got a great dick angry oh oh nice
oh you're being so specific I know
there's people should send balls nudes
only Oh mine are extremely I just like
if I come out of the ocean I'd literally
have a vagina
me too and outie belly I look like a
murderer hold sour wait why do you have
a vagina the ocean we it's so called the
ball get tucked in balls going like
ovaries all edgy and then my dick cheeks
so hard it's like a outie belly but I
only go in warm water so I was like what
the [ __ ] are you talking about
I see extremely adjustable and then on a
hot day they're kind of saggy like
playing a pendulum swinging around but
how's your dick turn like a [ __ ]
purple a teeter when it's so cold
yeah I've seen it purple anteater I
think you really should go to a doctor
it looks like a sea creature like I was
like what happened
alien I'm disgusted by my own dick how's
your dick it's pretty good man it's been
having a car
summer summer balls are not pleasant I
want a few budget or how was that it was
exhausting yeah it was we did 75 cities
holy [ __ ] that's a lot of City shows I
thought you liked many youtubers you
make
I mean it's six cities and [ __ ]
exhausted oh how many days I mean how
many 82 shows over I think we start on
January 29th and we ended last Saturday
or do you fly home in between oh it's
just so we usually fly out because la is
so far from like the rest is that the
rest of the country you we pretty much
almost always had to fly out red-eye on
Thursday night so wherever we were it's
going to fly and then we'd usually drive
from Friday show to Saturday to Sunday
and then fly back home Monday morning
that's your all deaf digital crew no
well yeah me Tony Baker and to hear more
we all worked in Doughboy we all work
with all different age you know um but I
knew Tony before all day I knew of Tony
before our death but I met del go into
here at all day that's cool that you're
able to go home and it's not just
completely on the road yeah but if
thinking back I see why people just tour
like 60 dates in two months or ten weeks
it's not come all about just just get it
over with
oh yes you could go like around the
country like that yeah and then you have
like you end up having more rest because
you're not flying back every day you
just like most people sleep overnight in
a bus we have a bus either so and
there's like so many times where we
couldn't get into the hotel Oh like we
have flight delays and it's just like
from January through August it was just
like oh we only lost it like completely
lost one no checking luggage no I
checked it in why cuz merch to carry so
and the more you fly the more luggage
gets lost ivory we got diverted and
delayed a lot but like completely lost
one time in Virginia like yeah your bag
didn't make the fly like you don't have
a choice
you know I thought about that but
because the way we do it doesn't really
work because we travel so much you don't
know how well it's gonna show so I end
up having too much to carry and then you
have like all these baggage fees so most
of your merch really delicate China so
you could yeah you could probably
there's some options maybe well so what
would happen sometimes we were shipping
merch to like venues and hotels and they
would refuse the shipment so that is
just catalyst yeah you that travel with
merch to and then we got lazy yeah so
much money emerge yeah yeah but then
someone has to sell it
someone definitely has to sell it you
got a carry you got a packet you have a
person that travels with you that kind
of like a my tour manager does emerge as
well man oh see we we didn't have yeah
when I first started it was just us like
selling the March and taking the
pictures but then that kind of like that
just got to be too much work it's a pain
in the ass you're like trying to tell
him how much your cars and your getting
changed like taking a picture and also
trying to connect with them because like
all of this content change my life so
much and your uncle bets 25 cents more
now I know why more tubers don't sell
delicate china as merch because that
would be a dish that's a huge question I
was thinking about coming out with a mug
and all that but you know I'm thinking
like really like a nice and trying to
find your branding on China big business
people love it my grandparents love it I
haven't seen fine china somebody's house
in a long time right yeah it's always in
that the cupboard mom's house growing up
I feel like I had like our parents had a
they use it nobody always behind glass
and we're not we don't really have it no
it's a waste we only use it Thanksgiving
dinner and Christmas dinner did you guys
also have like same real silverware yes
I had to polish that with every [ __ ]
year what's the point no like what why
do they have that if they don't use it
is it like another way towards math to
be a fancy thing it's supposed to be
like events Thanksgiving get-togethers
but then I think nowadays everyone's so
practical everyone just has the regular
set of utensils that they use all the
time I didn't realize so we're used to
really be made out of silver yeah they
used to really do that because the
platters and all that stuff
like when I would open the case like the
whatever it came in I'm like oh what the
hell is this she's like oh it's up mom's
like it's over you gotta polish it I
grew up in such a big family that we
didn't even use those shoes we just use
plastic I'm one of four kids and then
you know my folks and then any time that
we did Christmas you like we had all my
aunts uncles cousins everybody it's just
like it was only plastic forks and [ __ ]
okay it's easier how I just throw
everything away we use plastic to watch
all those dishes we use disposable
chopsticks nice that's true I do buy a
tea set recently in one of my travels
mmm but I just use it as decor if we
still have never used it for tea you
don't have fine tea I have fine team
London on tour ship hi - you're fine -
oh hi to you - afternoon tea just try to
help be able no sorry just the world
what is what is that what the hell is
the high to low team right I don't know
if those low tea with high tea is just
like tea sandwiches and like a whole
bunch of pastries it was amazing it's
like brunch it's it's similar timing but
the food isn't as heavy it's just like
finger sandwiches and they bring it all
on these Oh Oh the Governor's Ball oh
that's low tea do you guys like Earl
Grey or Ceylon oh great with milk with
honey they actually had sugar cubes
which I hadn't seen in a long time
remember those sugar cube with the
middle like flour something on top no
they had like little designs or whatever
on top my grandma always had yeah I was
at a diner recently and there's a
gigantic thing of butter in a bowl in
the middle of classes [ __ ] I thought
that was weird though I'm like this
can't be and it just keeps scooping it I
see yeah like shared butter it's like a
big giant yeah shared by seen they have
a phase I'm sure but
okay so you're to was worldwide then you
went to London we went to London
formed in London and Birmingham England
and then we I took my family I took my
wife out a lot I took my kids on you
were my kids just don't care they about
your tours no no go my dad's killing it
look at all these people can they think
you're lame yes dammit they go can you
order room service before you leave like
you don't play games and stuff I just
sat in the room and I took the Miss
Baylor can we go back to the hotel oh do
they know there's monkeys there it's
brain yeah no monkeys yeah you can
deserve theirs they're like publicly
around and stuff are you making this
[ __ ] up
no Tyler no Spain has monkeys my friend
went to Thailand I saw monkeys like on
the beach just just Chile that's cool
too high while I wasn't balling they
have that I lost the station grandpa
even when I was a thirty year old kid he
was obsessed with playing team fortress
classic it's just a computer game if you
told me there's monkeys outside I'm
outside kids like going outside are the
Apollo generations on stay inside inside
that's Jen's email Kenzi
and that's because technology we we went
outside because we had to that's true I
was the only way to play with your
friends
in order to play video games you had to
like sitting next to them but now they
play with their friends as much if not
more they just don't have to be next to
them to do it a plane outside is just
fun yeah but it was fun until got boring
like I remember I remember like getting
introduced to some higher class
entertainment like when I was like 12 13
including women and I was like oh hey my
friends sucks and riding bikes like kind
of sucks now you start digging all the
stuff I already knew that I was already
doing that for years though that's true
at 12 I didn't do that [ __ ] no more
always smoking weed see that is more
entertaining what's the transition
period from playing with toys to how you
start like junior high right I didn't
smoke weed though maybe levitation girls
for sure maybe 30 rounder I think cuz
you always have the buddy that has an
older brother you
they get introduced to it fast and and
there are the ones that introduced that
around the school yeah and they have
their parties and you want to be with
the older cool guys and they just
hanging out and you watched him drink
beer yes I didn't smoke weed at 12 I did
smoke cigarettes and those because my
friends older brothers already had
samurais they just pass them around
that's all we want to do is impress the
people older than us
yeah we're smoking that's cool we're so
lame yeah but I was in the DARE program
so I was like that's not cool and then I
got mask oh no I wish it then it didn't
work their program broke outlawed kids
asked me hey the games in our generation
just sucked like it was hard to get
hooked on like it's just you get bored
after they go hard on Tetris or
something you go hard but you could only
Tetris so much and time I tell you why I
gotta do some other [ __ ] it's because we
couldn't save them and you have to sit
there and beat the game yeah and
whenever you stopped and turn it off you
have to start all over now kids can save
the game so they get to go further in
the game and I think that's more
interesting and also community yes I
feel like the games are easier too oh
yeah I give you think about it now
easier than pac-man you try playing the
new Zelda game do that game [ __ ] me up
that game was infuriating they're easy
as in like I think the games back then
was easy to do but then the levels are
harder mm-hmm yeah I think the problem
is I just sucked so hard of games like a
head that game is [ __ ] hard it's so
hard like yeah I think is really good at
games but even he struggles peasant I
suck at games only good at sports games
fighting games RPG role players stuff do
you Madden I don't really play games at
all anymore once my kids were I remember
like when I stopped when my kids my
machines
once they like once he my oldest son
realized that the Xbox controller was
awfully he'd like I pay I pay and I just
had them one that was unplugged and then
once you realized that the light wasn't
on on his team you of mine he's like I
had no light and then I plug it in and
then just press pause and stopped it and
then I just was like this sucks
I could mess it I was literally like
just put the controller down I just was
like this is you know no good now I suck
through them like I try to play
fortnight with them they were like y'all
you're kill screen you just can't go
like I know but my son was like I know
you're trying to bond but this is cute
dad you're slowing us down actually it
just reminds me the worst thing just
happened to me as a parent I sent my 13
year old a meme and he was like I saw
this on the area the other day it's not
just like this is all dad's eight hours
old
like we just recently got a discord for
a JK yeah and so last night Stephen
Nicky were on and then Nicky text me
like hey you got to get on whatever so I
get on and then I'm trying to like
figure it out and then I asked Shawn
something I was like what's a afk and
then Isaac's right next to me he goes
mom you don't know what an a of K is
away from Keith look is it a gun yeah oh
no the discord no I know I know our
version of like K was our generation day
I never knew that away keyboard it was a
free time lol and all that stuff kids it
was always a keyboard yeah she was
always at chemo no I never knew that afk
and then so I was like wait I think how
do you know this and he was like I had a
discord but I've deleted it already
gonna like yeah right he's already
smarter than deleted at 11 yet Isaac
discord he's just sitting in Isaac chat
I thought my kids never text anybody
because I didn't know about discord I
was like like unlocking his phone and
checking his text make sure he's not
selling drugs man this dude never checks
anyone but he's always on his phone
because they use apps they use all kind
of apps remember you guys tell me about
the Gmail thing man your guys yeah okay
and then I saw you for you and I was
just I offered oh yeah god I just
finished you for yeah I'm like Jesus I'm
not having kids dude it's better
the world if we don't have teenagers
it's just like because my son's going to
high school next year what what a
nightmare
so now we know what our parents felt yes
every generation it's like the parents
are going on
teenagers are you [ __ ] crazy yes and
it's like you never think that that
would be euphoria Joe no not yet
oh you two like is he related to it hard
watch you for yeah I was like that was
my high school [ __ ] was it really so
when I went to high school everyone's on
drugs all the time sexually active it
was like it's kind like in the Asian
hood so it's like it's just masked
between like like Asian gang culture and
then so we would go raving and wake up
at random people's houses so like the
life and I watch you for you I'm like oh
[ __ ] this is transporting me back to my
life in high school so for me I think
what's different with my parents where
they go oh man teenagers are crazy I'm
like I know teenagers are crazy because
I was crazy yeah I always think that
it's like a portion of teenagers it's
not the standard cuz for me when I
watched it I thought it was like I mean
there's a lot of similarities to my high
school as well and Nicki especially
Nicki's because Nicki new all her
friends were on drugs out same [ __ ] they
were all doing all kinds of crazy [ __ ]
and so what she's watching it she's like
this was my [ __ ] high school crazy
yeah cuz I just get a lot of weed it and
it starts off intense it is like it's
not a slow start you don't want to binge
that [ __ ] yeah but you know what I like
about the boys superheroes would
absolutely be terrible yeah if you had
superpowers you like maybe you'll say
people even I mean screw you you see
some arrows for sure of course I'm
billing you regular human I can freaking
fly and they have laser eyes yeah yeah
robbing banks
that's what's nuts about spider-man I'm
like spider-man you can't pay your rent
just go [ __ ] lose Robin ATM who cares
yeah you're pretty cool like superheroes
will absolutely be corporatized that was
you think somebody's not gonna make
money off that cuz they're crazier than
athletes now yes I wish I could just
tell spider-man that money's insured
yeah this part means that me gotta eat
man it's just print I anyway
[Music]
[Music]